two brothers who in recent years appear
to have drifted apart
both at least it is clear united in the
respect they felt for their grandpa
as it was confirmed that prince harry is
back in the uk
he released a statement and this
photograph he was my grandpa
master of the barbecue legend of banter
and
cheeky right till the end he has been a
rock for her majesty the queen with
unparalleled devotion
by her side for 73 years of marriage and
while i could go on
i know that right now he would say to
all of us beer in hand
oh do get on with it his grandfather's
funeral will be the first time we've
seen him with the family since he moved
to america with megan and they did that
interview with oprah
some hoping shared grief will help with
reconciliation
not least with his brother prince
william who shared
this photograph of prince george with
the duke
and the words i feel lucky to have not
just had his example to guide me but his
enduring presence
well into my own adult life both through
good times
and the hardest days i will never take
for granted the special memories my
children will always have of their great
grandpa
coming to collect them in his carriage
and seeing for themselves his infectious
sense of adventure
as well as his mischievous sense of
humor i will miss my
grandpa but i know he would want us to
get on with the job
yes the tone of the two statements may
seem different harry's potentially more
relaxed
and william's a little more formal but
both are just
as respectful and the differences
probably aren't surprising when you
think of the personalities of the two
brothers
but also harry's new life and the future
role that william has got to come
as flags continue to fly at half-mast
politicians across the four nations pay
tribute
and though i suspect mr speaker that he
might be
embarrassed or even faintly exasperated
to receive these tributes
he made this country a better place
and for that he will be remembered with
gratitude
and with fondness for generations to
come
[Music]
for a man who was always expected to
leave matters of state to the queen
prince philip did at times stray towards
the political
stanley johnson the prime minister's
father and environmental campaigner met
him in the 1970s
and told me he was passionate and
influential
on issues like population growth and
it's not just a question of the
influence on one government or the
british government
i think there's been an international
and international influence too
the duke above all i think led the way
in saying
this is an issue for our time and it is
his legacy they want to take
center stage this week a family who may
have had their recent differences
now together to share their loss
rhiannon mills
sky news at windsor castle